well everybody it's really incredible i
decide hey you know what it'd be a great
thing to take a break from dealing with
a newborn baby and do a show
i check out what's been happening at the
trump riot hearings
and the big headline is big massive
dumps as if that's not what i've already
been dealing with at home uh incredible
incredible second day in the trump riot
hearings now of course many of you are
already familiar with this entire dumps
thing dumps yeah you guys remember that
right big massive dumps sure well
yesterday at the trump riot hearings
they actually played the video big
massive dumps trends on twitter after
january 6 committee airs infamous trump
interview with maria bartoromo big
massive dumps have gone completely
mainstream dominating yesterday's second
day of the trump riot hearings and my
audience of course knows about it this
is the original this was sort of setting
the stage
for explaining the different elements of
donald trump's campaign to steal the
election for those who may not remember
this is that uh critical moment in
american political history big massive
dumps and what happened if you watched
the election i was called by the biggest
people
uh saying congratulations political
people congratulations sir you just won
the election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and i'm sure you
felt that way sure this election was
over and then they did dumps they call
them dumps big massive dumps
uh in michigan and pennsylvania yeah and
uh
all over okay so that is one aspect of
all of the not only unproven but
debunked conspiracy theories about the
election and we're going to get into
more specific claims that the january 6
committee did a really good job of
saying here's the claim here's someone
who knows
saying it's bogus and this is
republicans mostly presenting this
testimony which we will get to but one
other aspect in general of thinking
about the january 6 riots is
was trump a factor
in the people that were rioting being
there rioting in other words were they
there because of something that donald
trump said and the january 6 committee
closed yesterday's hearing with a video
of exactly that of uh of trump
supporters saying
they were there because of the things
trump said including that there were
excuse the term massive dumps take a
listen to
now fake this
they think they're going to [ __ ]
shoot us out of our boat and put
confidence fighting in office it ain't
happening today but
you voted yes sir
voted early it went well except for uh
the
can't really trust the software
dominion software all over
we voted and right in the top right hand
corner of the dominion voting machine
that we used there was a wi-fi symbol
with five
without a doubt so they stole that from
us twice
we're not doing it anymore we're not
taking it anymore so we're standing up
we're here and
whatever happens we're not laying down
against pennsylvania
it didn't work
the absolute work it didn't work
no
200 000 people that weren't even
registered voted
[Music]
but if the election is being stolen what
is it going to take
[Music]
okay so of an individual coughing a lot
those are all specific claims being made
by trump and people around him so that's
the sort of broader context for
yesterday's hearings let's now get into
some of the specific claims
every central claim
about the 2020 election
made by failed former president donald
trump and the people around him
including people like mark meadows but
also wackier people like sydney powell
mike pillow lindell and others
every single one of those claims was
systematically contradicted
and uh debunked
by
mostly republican testimony as we saw
during yesterday's second day of the
trump riot hearings i'm going to give
you some examples here and you will see
how comprehensively every single one of
these claims is easily easily easily uh
refuted former philadelphia city
commissioner al schmidt a republican
said
there is no evidence of even eight dead
people voting never mind the 8 000 dead
voters that trump and people around him
claimed in the claim that dead people
were voting in fact mr giuliani told
pennsylvania state legislators that 8
000 dead people voted in pennsylvania
you investigated those claims of voter
fraud
can you tell us what you found
not only was there not evidence of 8 000
dead voters
voting in pennsylvania there was an
evidence of eight
we took seriously every case that was
referred to us
no matter how fantastical no matter how
absurd and took every one of those
seriously including these
so it's not that they say well every you
have to investigate all of it
it was investigated you just don't like
the outcome of that investigation and
we've so
dead voters that's one bucket of claims
we've looked into it extensively uh
there was an investigation i believe it
was in michigan where they started with
a list of suppo i believe it was 10 000
supposedly dead voters um and again i
now and i believe it was the guardian if
not the bbc they said let's randomly
choose um i think it was 35 of the
thousand or to 2000 whatever let's
investigate them and then with those 35
they found most of them there was
evidence that the people were alive like
there was just really no reason to think
that they were dead
in a few cases it was people who were
indeed alive at the time that they voted
and then they when they mailed them
their ballot then they died nothing
illegal there in some cases there was
like junior senior confusion i mean it
was all it was all just picked apart
next claim um georgia smuggled ballots
former acting deputy attorney general
testifies that he personally
investigated the georgia smuggled
ballots
found nothing told him it was false but
it didn't matter
play again
a testimony from mr donahue who appeared
before the committee before today
mr donahue you we talked at some like
about um whether or not the white house
or the president was informed about the
antrim report
on the um results of the investigations
the interviews that had gone on on
fulton county
um
how would those results have been
communicated
to the white house to the president
i don't know how they were initially
communicated i do know that they came up
in subsequent conversations with the
president and dad rose and i essentially
told him we looked into that and it's
just not true
okay so he wasn't he was informed
i told the president myself that several
times in several conversations that
these allegations about ballots being
smuggled in
in a suitcase and run through the
machine several times it was not true
that we looked at we looked at the video
we interviewed the witnesses it was not
true right we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines so there is
another claim the idea of ballots
smuggled in and there were
videos with ominous music of suitcases
in different places with no reason
whatsoever to believe that the suitcases
contained fraudulent ballots people have
suitcases it's not like a huge smoking
gun in and of itself and trump was told
and yet he continued to repeat it and
then lastly again just as another
example we could do this all day but i
won't do it to you the other claim was
more votes than voters in philadelphia
of philadelphia and pennsylvania in
general became a big focus because they
stopped counting and then started again
of course if you understand the
scheduling for vote counting in
philadelphia you would know that they
just have a schedule they stop counting
and then they start again the next
morning not really evidence of anything
but the other claim was more votes than
voters and william barr trump's own
attorney general says it's not true
there were not more votes than voters
and anybody just googling philadelphia
pennsylvania population would be able to
realize that like to turn to president
trump's false allegations about election
integrity in philadelphia the attorney
general discussed these allegations at
some length
you know the idea
the president has repeatedly suggested
that there was some kind of outpouring
of unexpected votes in inner city areas
like philadelphia as recently as january
13th when he walked off the npr set
he was asked by the
interviewer what's you know what's your
evidence of fraud and he said more
people voted in philadelphia than there
were voters
and that was absolutely rubbish
the turnout in philadelphia was in line
with the state's turnout and in fact it
was not as
as impressive as many uh suburban
counties and uh
there was nothing uh
strange about the philadelphia uh
turnout it wasn't like there was all
these unexpected votes that came out in
philadelphia
so right
you know i think once you actually look
at the votes and then
there's an obvious explanation he
you know for example in pennsylvania
trump ran weaker than the republican
ticket generally he ran weaker than two
of the state
uh candidates anyway the point is
william barr knows that it was all bs so
every single one of these claims what do
we know about them we know two important
things
one there was not actually any evidence
for them but maybe even more importantly
two
there were republicans around trump who
knew the claims were bs
and would tell trump that they were bs
and it did not matter so a very critical
moment
in yesterday's trump riot hearings last
thing i want to look at on the trump
riot hearings day two before we go to a
break
there are often stories that become
stories
for good reason like for example that
rudy giuliani was appearing regularly
drunk in different places and was giving
people bad advice on the basis of being
drunk and whenever it would come up and
we've talked about it before there were
people on the right who would just deny
it and there would be some who would
come out and say you're making fun of
alcoholism and of course we are not
making fun of alcoholism alcoholism is a
serious disease very serious horrible
horrible disease
the issue was whether there are people
close to donald trump giving him advice
who are not in a proper state of mind to
be doing so and it was widely reported
that rudy giuliani
was moved from appearing on tv at night
to the morning with the idea that maybe
he would not be drunk in those cases and
it was just a widely understood and
reported thing
well yesterday's hearing started with
liz cheney one of the things that turned
out in the investigation is that rudy
giuliani was regularly drunk and giving
donald trump advice and
you know to be perfectly frank
it sort of makes everything more logical
because the storyline that trump
ultimately attached to
makes a lot more sense if you say it
it's an inebriated person's storyline
it's like oh okay well that so
obvious that it sounds like what a drunk
person would say happened at the
election take a listen you will hear
first-hand testimony that the
president's campaign advisors urged him
to await the counting of votes and not
to declare victory on election night
the president understood even before the
election that many more biden voters had
voted by mail because president trump
ignored the advice of his campaign
experts and told his supporters only to
vote in person
donald trump knew before the election
that the counting of those mail-in
ballots in several states would not
begin until late in the day would not be
complete for multiple days
this was expected reported and widely
known
you will also hear testimony that
president trump rejected the advice of
his campaign experts on election night
and instead followed the course
recommended by an apparently inebriated
rudy giuliani
to just claim he won
and insist that the vote counting stop
so one of the big questions and one of
the big things that is fascistic and
authoritarian is
just say you won just say you won is
sort of the
motto of this entire
this entire farce right just say you won
and that's what trump did he came out at
two something in the morning uh on
election day and said i i won
and we now have learned it was
apparently the drunk idea of rudy
giuliani and of course just as a
reminder many instances of rudy
apparently drunk here's one that we
covered um this was a 9 11 dinner where
rudy
very very
not with it rudy
can imagine tony blanken or miley
how's that guy a general
jesus
the other day he said that the bagram
air force base is not strategically
important
i wanted to grab this what is that 5
stars 10 stars 12 stars he has so many
stars that coming up into his ears
i wanted to grab his stars shove it down
his throat and say it's 400 miles from
china
china is going to be our enemy for the
next 40 years
you have an air base 400 miles from them
and you're giving it up idiot right yeah
that may be the most drunk anyone has
ever been at any kind of major speech so
every claim
backed up by the investigation so far
day three is today and we will have more
coverage tomorrow quick break back after
this find me on twitter at deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com okay let's
do a little bit more coverage of
yesterday's second day of the january
sixth committee hearings another
major and obvious scam that we all knew
about except of course for the millions
of trumpists who donated to it is that
this so-called trump official election
defense fund which was going to fund
recounts and lawsuits and audits and all
these different things
it was a scam it was a grift it was if
you looked at the fine print
obviously another attempt for trump to
enrich himself by raising money and then
enrich his friends and family by hiring
friends and family and paying them out
of those donated funds well it's another
thing we suspected which the january 6
committee has now apparently confirmed
to be true
we have a video from yesterday's hearing
where a congresswoman zoe lofgren
explains that the trump official
election defense fund didn't actually
exist it was yet another trump grift and
again a grift which victimizes his
supporters
progressives were not donating to
trump's election defense fund it is a
grift of his own supporters i'm senior
investigative counsel with the house
select committee to investigate the
january 6 attack on the united states
capitol
between election day and january 6 the
trump campaign sent millions of
fundraising emails to trump supporters
sometimes as many as 25 a day
the emails claimed the quote left-wing
mob was undermining the election
implored supporters to quote step up to
protect the integrity of the election
and encourage them to quote fight back
but as the select committee has
demonstrated the trump campaign knew
these claims of voter fraud were false
yet they continued to barrage small
dollar donors with emails encouraging
them to donate to something called the
official election defense fund
the select committee discovered no such
fund existed
i don't believe there is actually a fund
called the election defense fund
deferred to say that election defense
fund was another is i think we've called
it a marketing tactic yes
and tell us about these funds as
marketing tactics
uh
just the topic matter
where money could potentially go to be
how money could potentially be used
the claims that the election was stolen
were so successful
president trump and his allies raised
250 million dollars
250 million dollars remember when i
brought the story of the griff to you
only about 70 million had been raised
and then okay we figured out it's
another grift i wasn't going to keep
updating you about the amount of money
by the time it was all said and done 250
million dollars had been raised and it's
a grift all the way down as an example
of how the grift was even further used
for enriching trump's friends and family
kimberly guilfoyle the then girlfriend
maybe now fiance or wife i don't know of
don jr
she spoke for two and a half minutes at
the rally on january 6th she was
reportedly paid 60 grand for that speech
and that is the money that came from the
so-called election defense fund which
it's sort of like if i were to say
if ever to say hey please donate to the
democracy defense fund at the david
pakman show
if if you're just making a donation to
the david pakman show just because i
call it something doesn't mean it exists
and it doesn't mean it's being used for
that like it just gets mixed in with the
money that comes in for memberships and
whatever else just because you put on an
email official election defense fund
doesn't mean it's a real thing and this
was so obvious that it was going on
that the sad part is it's news to people
and many of the small donors who got
grifted and scammed are never going to
know it now is it a crime that's a great
question congresswoman zoe lofgren was
asked is that a crime and she said it's
for someone else to decide we're a
legislative committee
and
it's clear that he intentionally misled
his donors asked him to donate to a fund
that didn't exist
and used um the money raised for
something other than what he said now
it's for someone else to decide whether
that's criminal or not that's not the
purview of a legislative company yes and
merrick garland attorney general said
they are certainly watching the hearings
at the justice department but who knows
what the outcome will be another scam
another grift not a surprise to viewers
and listeners of this show
i have some fascinating audio and video
to play for you
in the midst of the january 6 committee
hearings
rudy giuliani said on his podcast which
was released right as the house
committee was holding its hearings
rudy puts out a podcast and he says he
admits to the entire thing he says the
whole point of the rally on january 6th
and of subsequently going down to the
capitol the point of it the goal of it
the objective
was to try to get electoral votes that
donald trump didn't actually earn
listen to the language rudy uses here
okay you you really have to this is one
of those it's linguistically
important to listen to the words used
and the president put out the first uh
notice
of this rally which actually was
somewhere in mid-december for a january
6 rally
on the day that the electoral college
vote was going to be taken
uh the whole purpose of it was
a rally in support of the president's
uh bid
for uh electoral votes in the sense that
he had proven and shown that he had
really won these states and he was being
deprived of these states
unfairly and illegally
a bid the point of the rally was to
support trump's bid for electoral votes
you don't bid
for electoral votes you either won them
or you didn't and it is really i i know
the egg man's going to
write in about it
it's kafka-esque language you don't make
a bid for electoral votes you don't make
a case for electoral votes you don't
argue about electoral votes you don't
rally you either win them or you don't
how do you how can a rally of people
saying things
be an argument for electoral votes you
either won them or you didn't and if you
think
that something was wrong you fight it in
court
that's the venue where you fight it
where trump tried to fight it and i
believe it was 68 cases
63 or 68 cases that he lost that's the
one venue where you argue
for electoral votes and it's an
admission
that the whole point of what happened on
january 6 was
try to get votes you didn't actually win
end of story case in point and rudy
giuliani admitting to the entire thing
all right one more story before we move
on to other things sort of in this world
of election fraud and claims and riots
and all these different things
former white house counsel norm eisen is
now saying that he believes trump is
likely to be prosecuted
in georgia and this i got a bunch of
emails about this
this is sort of separate from the trump
riot hearings this is this is
specifically in the state of georgia
business insider reporting former white
house special counsel says trump is
likely to be prosecuted in georgia
because of particularly strong evidence
former president donald trump could be
prosecuted in georgia for his attempts
to overturn the state's election results
in 2020. norm eisen former white house
special counsel for ethics told cnn it's
likely trump will be prosecuted because
of particularly strong evidence quote i
think the evidence is particularly
strong for a prosecution in the state of
georgia where the atlanta d.a has
convened a special grand jury remember
that that's where fulton county d.a
fannie willis wanted a special grand
jury to look at trump's attempts to
overturn the election there the grand
jury was convened
last month you have to recall that this
is the
state in which trump wanted those 11
780 votes that he didn't earn i need 11
000 votes give me a break and that is
very very strong evidence it's a clear
attempt to extort this was after
the third recount in december of 2020
which confirmed again
joe biden won georgia you might remember
that georgia took a while to flip to
blue on the map that most media outlets
were using because it was being
challenged in a more real way than what
was being done in other states joe biden
won it
and donald trump is on a recording
after we knew that he had lost saying
find me the votes
saying there's nothing wrong with saying
hey you've recalculated and look it
turns out that donald trump actually won
and remember that when the georgia
secretary of state wouldn't go with it
and i i don't believe that the georgia
secretary of state is great in any way
but he was unwilling to go with it
donald trump then started the mob boss
type underhanded threats listen
this is going to be costly in many ways
trump said
costly in many ways it is straight up
mob vocabulary and he's recorded doing
it so the question now this is parallel
to the january 6th investigation
is there going to be an indictment are
there going to be charges coming out of
georgia and i know listen i'm with
everybody
even if you get charges it doesn't
necessarily mean anything major is going
to happen but charging a former
president is a really big deal
if they're just there being charges
would be a major major deal we will have
all of these clips on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
bottom line it for me at the end of the
day
where are you right now does trump get
charged anywhere
uh federally georgia
pennsylvania just any will there be any
charges against trump or not let me know
your thoughts in a comment in a tweet in
an email to info davidpakman.com
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show today
we're going to be speaking with sheila
heen who's a harvard law school
professor founder of triad consulting
and also co-author of the new york times
bestsellers difficult conversations as
well as thanks for the feedback sheila
it's really great to have you on today
i'm delighted to be here
so i've every week i get questions from
people in my audience um i have this
very big political disagreement with my
mom and i want to know how to handle it
or i have this difficult situation with
my co-workers politically and i want to
know how to handle it and
people ask me for advice and one of the
first things i say is well to figure out
the right path forward you kind of first
have to think about what you want the
outcome to be in other words in a
political disagreement with your mom
what's more important proving her wrong
or maintaining a relationship with your
mom for example depending on what what
you expect might happen so can you kind
of open up by giving us a basic
framework in terms of how to think
generally about some of these difficult
conversations that people sometimes have
absolutely and and david i think you're
right on the money meaning
i think one of the core questions is
what is my purpose
in having a conversation because if my
purpose is to prove her wrong that that
is not necessarily going to change her
mind you may have noticed that true
right because it's totally clear to you
that you have proven her wrong
and yet
her views persist right um and so i
think that's part of the struggle which
is that um i actually think that there
are things that are hard about just
being in relationship with someone
who holds a view that you find
incredibly
disturbing upsetting
wrong-headed
um foolish uninformed should we keep
going
all those things yeah right right and
and it's important also because there's
a range of the example i give often is
when people say are you friends with
like radical right people for example
i'll say listen if someone thinks the
tax rate should be two points lower than
i do it's not a big deal it's just a
disagreement and we can kind of just
work through that it's not really going
to affect too many things about my
ability to relate to them if they
believe there's a secret cabal of jews
controlling every aspect of you know
where that's going to be a little bit
different in terms of our ability to
really relate to each other so it seems
like that context is important too
i think that that's exactly right and um
and so i think what we're talking about
are
views that feel like they hit at the
core of who we are yes
or that
suggest a threat to something that we
hold really
dear
and so
in this weird way there's like an
identity issue that comes with like how
could i
being who i am and what i care about and
um what i want people to
see about who i am and respect about who
i am how could i be
fill in the blank friends with
family with neighbors with coworkers
with this person who the at least the
caricature of the view that they hold in
some way invalidates dismisses
or oppresses
something that really matters to me
about who i am and just that um
that identity
quake that comes with that question i
think is why we feel like we need to
have a conversation with them right
and what's what would thinking of
techniques
you know sometimes it'll be like hey we
need to talk or
you said something that really offended
me starting with how one felt there's
all these different tactics that that
are often mentioned
is there some universal best way to kind
of start some of these conversations or
does it really depend on who the person
is and what you're going to talk about
so i think that the the thing that it
depends most on is negotiating with
yourself about your purpose yeah
so for instance the the couple of
examples that you just gave if they just
said something or did something
that i want to raise well then there is
a purpose to the conversation and my
purpose would be
um i want to share with you
sort of what impact that had for me or
why i found it
upsetting or frustrating or
[Music]
that you're not really understanding
something that feels important to me for
you to understand right so my purpose is
actually to share something with you and
to feel heard well that's a purpose i
might be able to achieve
right right
um and if if i've got my purpose aligned
with something that feels realistic well
then i can start by just sharing that
purpose like hey whether or not you
agree i want you to understand why this
matters to me
that would be a great purpose and
depending on the relationship they may
or may not say like okay or they may
start explaining why you're wrong right
yeah you know when i spoke to um once i
i spoke to someone who has hired and
fired lots of people and i think this
will be kind of parallel to what we're
talking about
and he said one of the things he doesn't
like which he did early in his career
when he would have to fire someone is he
would bring them in and he would go
listen um so i want to talk because
things haven't been going so well lately
and then the employee might say they
haven't i think things have been going
fine you're already derailed right and
you're kind of trying to back up and so
his his thing was he would go
listen thanks for meeting with me we're
gonna have to let you go let me explain
to you why
and then you're putting out front that
there's a decision and there's a reality
here and now it's just a matter of kind
of thinking it through and talking it
through
is that where does that fit into the
techniques that you think can be useful
and is there something about that to
instead of listen um remember the other
day when we were talking about i was
like no i don't remember that just like
we we had a conversation that left me
feeling really upset with you and i want
to tell you what happened i want to is
there something about that as a
technique
totally totally so so one of the things
that you're describing is what we would
call a bad news conversation
like there's something uh that has been
decided or there's something that
matters to me
and the purpose of this conversation is
partly to let you know that yeah and if
the purpose of the conversation is to
let you know that then i need to put the
bad news up front and what's funny is
that if you ask people
if somebody has bad news for you or
needs to tell you something important
what what are your
requests of them yeah almost everybody
says like just tell me up front like
don't tiptoe into it or hide the ball or
make me guess
but then when we're on the other side of
the conversation we ease into it
i've watched someone try to fire someone
by asking them questions
right
but don't you think you'd be better off
you know at a different organization and
not really it was a friend of theirs
right so we do it because
because of some of the identity stuff
that i was talking about like i'm not
the kind of person who hurts people's
feelings i'm not the kind of person who
treats someone unfairly and and that's
why
a lot of
getting ready to have a important
conversation
means negotiating with yourself like
well what's true you might hurt their
feelings yeah let's maybe you are
sensitive and and
maybe that's okay
and you need to let them know like look
this is just a topic on which i am
sensitive yeah we don't argue about
whether i'm normal sensitive or over
sensitive or you're insensitive
but if we're gonna be in a relationship
with each other this is where we're at
one of the other um situations that
often comes up in the political space
and this is less about people in my
audience but more about some of the
people that i talk about politicians or
public figures is allegations are often
made against people of all all different
kinds
and then often there's like an instant
evaluation of how an individual reacts
when accused of something and
unfortunately what can be difficult
about it is
no matter how you react it's sort of
seen as though like of course that's
what being what's being said you know
and and whether the allegation is of
some kind of criminality we've seen this
in the context of the metoo movement you
know all sorts of allegations
and if people say i i absolutely didn't
do that
the reaction can often be well that's
what everybody would say at least
initially right or most most people
would or
you kind of get the idea when there are
accusations being hurled
at you
what are some of the ways that
are
better to respond maybe than what we
often see
well so um
i'll give an answer that i actually
learned from someone else so years ago
um
we were doing a program
in collaboration with another group and
and the other group included
people who did internal investigations
within the cia fbi et cetera and so what
they were teaching
was
um how to read signals that someone
might not be giving you the straight
story yep
so one of the things that i learned from
them is that one of the most common
red flags is what's called a protest
answer
so
if you accuse me of fill in the blank
rather than saying i absolutely did not
do that the person says
i can't even believe you had asked me
that
i can't even believe you would have the
nerve to et cetera et cetera so
what's interesting is not that if i'm a
truthful person and i didn't do what's
being accused that i wouldn't be
horrified that you're even asking or
suspecting me
um but what they would say is
if you are
innocent and telling the truth the truth
is your friend so the first thing you're
going to blurt out is the truth which is
like of course not then you can add
i can't even believe you're asking me
that
so
so what's interesting is that you feel
if you're on the the being accused side
of it you feel both things
and and it can be tempting to think like
i shouldn't even have to say i didn't do
it
but do say that you didn't do it right
so like a reaction like
why would i do that that might be where
we say well you're not really denying it
i mean is that sort of the
non-responsive to the question yeah yeah
yeah the other the other um observation
that i learned from them was that
the biggest mistake we make if we
suspect something is going on is that we
don't ask the direct question right
right and they're like just ask the
direct question and get a direct answer
one way or another and it's not that
that proves anything
like you can't be a human lie detector
but it's at least a flag to say like uh
you might want to look into it a little
bit more
yeah in in police interviewing
techniques which i've read about a bit
one of the things that's often said and
you know whether these things are always
true or mostly true i guess it depends
depends on circumstances but it's when
you're interviewing a truly innocent
suspect
they will typically get really mad as
you continue to imply or suggest that
they did something they will genuinely
get mad that they are being accused of
this whereas guilty people will do some
of the things you're saying or or kind
of react in other ways because it's
genuinely infuriating to be accused of
something that you just you just didn't
do
yeah so so i think that's really
important which is it's not that you
don't feel the fury or the indignance
so so um being transparent about that
even as you are simultaneously being
transparent about what is not true
right let me also say david that this is
related to most difficult conversations
because we're often having the
conversation because something is wrong
yeah right something has gone wrong
somebody screwed something up somebody
did or said something that's a problem
um and the and blame is a feature of
most of those conversations if it's not
explicit it's implicit like you know we
need to talk about the fact that you
don't seem to know how to run zoom right
or use your microphone what is wrong
with you
and and
if the purpose of the conversation is
actually to fix the problem blame is
often not helpful
um because it's basically saying let's
talk about why you're the problem here
i'm the good guy and the victim and you
are the person who screwed it up and is
incompetent right it's not surprising
that not many people really want to be
part of that conversation like no thank
you i don't want to be in that play
with that being cast in that role so
so part of what we talk about if you're
actually trying to problem solve
is um
shifting to talking about joint
contribution like what do we each do or
fail to do that got us where we're at
because that'll tell us what we need to
change if we're going to fix the problem
and not
have it reoccur right or be in the same
place
next week that's a little bit different
than the political situations that
you're talking about because they're not
actually trying to solve a problem no
it's usually about trying to to appear
as though you got one over on whoever
else you're speaking to or whatever the
case may be and that's really at cross
purposes with much of the productive
ways to have these conversations i mean
it's interesting because uh 80 of
political speech in the united states is
sort of structurally not even designed
to achieve anything
well what it's structurally designed to
achieve is not a conversation with the
other side right it's a conversation
with your face right yes so
so you are saying it because you think
it is going to persuade or influence
someone or something it's just not what
we're pretending it is across the aisle
or
um across party lines
when it comes to when you're in the
middle of some kind of tense exchange
and this could be a debate i'm having on
my show with someone who disagrees with
me or someone talking to their mom about
whatever they said or you know whatever
the case may be often times there's this
the the emotion kind of blocks your
ability to really think and then after
the fact you often say i knew so many
other things that i could have said but
i didn't say etc how how can you stay
kind of level-headed during these
exchanges
well so i would um
i would distinguish between
being emotional
and sharing emotion
because i would argue that you in those
exchanges you've actually got two layers
of things going on one is the debate
that we're trying to have or the issues
that we're trying to
what get one over on person yes you're
right or just better understand and so
part of the advice is shift your purpose
to can we understand why we see this
differently
if we can shift from proving that i'm
right to
it seems so obvious that i'm
right i'm just trying to understand why
we see it differently that's actually a
productive conversation
but you've got a second layer going on
under the surface which is the emotions
and relationship layer that that is all
about how i feel treated in this
exchange
yeah one tool along those lines that um
i've been told by a couple of different
people is it can be useful to say okay
let's say the topic is abortion uh i'm
pro-choice i'm talking to someone who's
against abortion
ask the other person why they believe
you are pro-choice to even see if they
understand even if they disagree with
your framework how you came to the
conclusion and that number one it's good
for everybody to have the knowledge but
just the ex exercise of it might put the
person in a position that where they
just by even saying it they might at
least be more willing to understand your
view if not agree with it
i think that that's right and and what
it highlights is that in any
really good conversation
um or attempt to influence by the way um
you need two
things you need high quality
assertion like that you share your view
with
clarity and thoughtfulness and etc but
you also actually need high quality
empathy
that you are really listening generously
and deeply to each other to not to
because i think i'm going to agree with
you but because in order to understand
what might be persuasive to you i
actually have to understand what you
think and why you think it yes
and then i can say well so here's what
it feels like is left out of your view
or that i worry about that it sounds
like you're not so worried about so talk
to me about that so so when we talk
about high quality assertion it actually
has to be rooted in deep empathy and and
generous listening
so the move that you just suggested
um is a clever move although it's
basically backing the other person in
the corner to say be empathetic to me
first right and some people will take
that and say like yeah no i actually
think i can articulate your view and
that's helpful but if that doesn't work
it may be because you actually have to
do it first right that you need to say
so let me see if i can describe what
you're saying and why you
think what you think or feel the way
that you feel and then you can tell me
what's left out of that
and then
once they feel like you you really get
it their view
then you're in a great position to
basically say like
okay so let me say a little bit about
why i see this differently and i i would
love it if you could
see if you can summarize it back to me
because this is just a complicated issue
right and that sense of reciprocity
which is one of the most robust findings
in the literature
like if you attack me i'm going to
attack you back
um but if if you're willing to listen to
me and consider
genuinely authentically why i think what
i think or feel how i feel well then
i almost feel an obligation to do the
same for you right so that would be like
with the abortion example it might be
hey listen
my my belief is you're against it
because you believe life starts at
conception so that any abortion is is
like a murder and
can you give me a sense of why you think
i am pro-choice and and so i'm kind of
doing it first in a sense
yes you can um or
you might even tweet the question to say
can you give me a sense
and that's a genuine can you or do you
feel like you need more context from me
in order to understand that right
right because there's the
there's the general view of why people
are on each side of this issue but then
there's the you view like why do you
david care about this right
and
often around these really important hot
issues political issues um one of the
things that i hear is just differences
in what people worry most about
so someone who is pro-life worries most
about the life of the
child
they would say child sure
and murder someone who is pro-choice
worries most about
other people making choices for
individuals and what's interesting is
that if you we take a couple steps back
politically republicans
often worry most about
individual choice
and government interference in
individual choices which of course
in abortion that's flipped yes
um whereas democrats
often worry most about
the voices of those who are oppressing
not in the majority and equity right
or fairness and so
often one of the the ears i have on the
conversation is whatever it is we're
talking about what is it that each of us
is worried most about
and in some ways i don't have to worry
about what you're worried about because
i know that you'll take care of it right
if there wasn't anybody protecting
individual
autonomy or choice from government i
would have to worry about it but i can
rely on you guys to worry about it so so
i can worry about something else that
actually
matters to us as a society as well
super interesting we've been speaking
with harvard law school professor sheila
heen a co-author of the new york times
bestsellers difficult conversations as
well as thanks for the feedback really
appreciate your time today thank you so
much
thank you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
as you might have heard there are people
peacefully protesting at the supreme
court now when i use the term peacefully
protesting i actually mean it i'm not
referring to the trump riots of january
6th which were extraordinarily violent
and criminal and saying it was a
peaceful protest i'm actually talking
about just peaceful protest protected by
the first amendment with permits even
permits for the speech um and yesterday
florida of republican governor ron
desantis was in new york and he said
that those protesters at the supreme
court are engaging in an insurrection
and this is something we've seen many
times from republicans when they do a
thing they start saying uh it is the
left who is actually doing that thing
when a word starts to be part of the
milieu
uh uh they start to use the word and try
to redefine it or change it which is
funny because it's what they accuse the
left of doing oh the left is trying to
redefine woman
the left is trying to read this and
right but now you're saying that just a
protest is an insurrection because you
don't like the fact that your side did a
horrible riotous insurrection attempt on
january 6th of 2021 so let's look at
what ron desantis said not sounding i
will say like the biggest supporter of
the first amendment here what they're
trying to bring
is attention to the fact that the
supreme court may overturn roe v wade
later today or then again the coverage
could come out
next week when they uh
ultimately do issue their opinion
well i think that we have a rule of law
in this country and you don't get to
just have a mob descend on a supreme
court justice's house or try to impede
the operations of government because
there may be a decision you don't like
that would be considered an insurrection
to stop a court from functioning and yet
they seem to be able to get away with a
lot more
than if the shoe were on the other foot
so okay so listen we we have to break
these things down one by one first and
foremost
the armed person who went to kavanaugh's
house
absolutely outrageous
seemingly criminal arrest him charge him
throw the book at him 100 percent in
terms of the protests in general at the
judges at the justices houses i've
already said it is for law enforcement
and the justice department to figure out
when is it legal and when is it not
there are elements of that that are
absolutely protected by free speech uh
and there are elements of it that may go
over and it has to do with the specifics
of where the protest is taking place etc
but the protesters at the supreme court
are not trying to shut down the supreme
court they are making their voices heard
and it is a permitted peaceful protest a
real permitted peaceful protest unlike
what happened on january 6th and uh
think of the absurdity right i mean on
the one hand they want us to believe
january 6th was fine
uh despite the fact that there were vi
there was violence there were people
entering the building there were people
chanting to hang the vice president
there were people stealing stuff there
were people breaking windows that was
nothing that was fine it was peaceful it
was tourists it was whatever on the
other hand the current supreme court
protests no violence
they have permits
they're not entering the building
they're not chanting to hang anyone
they're not stealing stuff they're not
breaking windows
that we're supposed to believe is an
insurrection and of course hopefully the
interviewer would point that out and ask
a follow-up question but at the end of
the day it is fox news by the way there
they haven't even built gallows to hang
anyone at the supreme court protests
which is a an interesting notable thing
so the real concern here is i mean
listen desantis is a clown but the real
concern is
if these people get power back in
november in the house and or senate
which they may
if desantis becomes the next president i
mean i know it's early but he's doing
really well in 2024 primary polling and
he's not even running
um and he's less incompetent than trump
it's not inconceivable that he could
become president
if these people get power and they may
get it back soon
what does it actually mean for peace for
real peaceful protest what does it mean
for criticism of the government or
whatever the case may be
extraordinarily scary and dystopian
stuff so you all know i like a good
conspiracy theory not just because
i don't know sometimes they're
entertaining but
the way people come to believe things is
very interesting but also the sort of
suspensions of disbelief
the lack of skepticism that sometimes
goes with some conspiracy theories is
also really interesting and i don't know
if it has to do with the sort of
commitment and desperation to believe
something or what but we're going to
look at an example here our friends over
at the good liars in fact jason from the
good liars
spoke to uh a guy
um who
uh believes that john f kennedy is still
alive and currently president of the
united states now some we're going to
play the clip some of you may remember
the jfk stuff has actually been sort of
prominent over the last couple of years
and one of the really funny things is
there's lots of people who have bought
into the jfk conspiracy theories but
they're a little bit confused about john
f kennedy the guy who was president
versus john f kennedy jr and uh there
was this really funny clip i played for
you a few months ago of protesters
saying
jfk
is the president and then they go wait j
do you mean jfk junior or j and they go
yeah no
they're like arguing with each other as
to which one it is because they don't
really remember okay so that's the setup
here's another guy who says right now
jfk is the president and jfk jr is the
vice president which is a new spin on
this one explain the shirt to us donald
trump john f kennedy
and
jonathan kennedy jr she's uh vice
president there he's the vice president
danny is our president
so you gotta explain this you got to
explain this to me so so john f kennedy
senior is president right now
senior president right now yes
you're being serious right now i'm being
serious
and and didn't he because remember in
dallas he was he was riding
and then somebody shot and his brains
went all over jackie yeah something like
that
but that you're saying that didn't
happen
right that didn't happen so the reason i
love this one is there's two layers it's
not new
that people sometimes claim
john f kennedy wasn't really killed
right in in 1963.
in dallas it just didn't happen that way
and in fact there's actually more than
that there's he was killed
but not by lee harvey oswald or not only
by lee harvey oswald okay so that's like
one set of things then you go to he
wasn't actually killed at all
and okay like imagine that he hadn't
been killed at all
but then there's the the wackiest part
which is john f kennedy would be 105
years old right now
and that's where it actually starts to
get funny because many of these people
are confused about jfk versus jfk junior
jfk if he were still alive today would
be 62 years old i'm sorry jfk jr
john f kennedy would be 105 years old
today if he were still alive so if you
can get beyond he wasn't really
assassinated which already takes a lot
anything involving john f kennedy senior
today you're talking about a man who
would be 105 years old and that
particular element seems to be
completely missing from the critical
thinking of these individuals now beyond
beyond that kind of funny thing
i don't really know why the jfk stuff
has has seen a resurgence in the last
year and a half as related to donald
trump
um and i mean i'm open to hearing from
people why you think that we've seen all
sorts of conspiracy theories relating to
trump like trump is truly still the
president
the military is still under the control
of donald trump uh there's a shadow
government
uh whatever right okay fine but trump's
in his mid 70s so it's plausible
why all of a sudden shifting to the the
would-be now 105 year old john f kennedy
it doesn't make any sense to me maybe
it's just things go in cycles and we're
back to jfk one way or another maybe
it'll happen again when jfk would have
been 120 years old in 15 years i don't
know but let me know your thoughts as to
why the jfk stuff is such a big deal to
so many of these trump people
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p as many of you know i
will sometimes use the phrase if all you
have is a hammer
right if all you have is a hammer we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines no no i don't know that i would
call a hammer a machine i would call it
a tool if all you have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail and if you
are obsessed with vaccine conspiracy
theories
then any time anything happens to anyone
you point to vaccines our old friend
eric from mass called in
about justin bieber and haley bieber's
recent health troubles what do you think
he blames for them take a listen
hey david it's eric from math uh
what do you think that justin bieber and
haley beaver both getting vaccine
injured
um paralysis of the face um
a stroke and a quad to haley paralysis
of the face for uh bieber it's all
listed there from the vaccine that's a
fact
there's no disputing that
oh hey uh good luck with your uh kid on
the way that sounds uh that sounds great
um
too bad you won't have uh the same
income with the site and you'll have to
find another way but if you're a
resourceful guy i'm sure he'll be all
right yep no i'm actually i'm gonna be
doing uh i don't know how many of you
know about barista fire it's quite a
movement and uh i'm really the real
reason i've had my espresso machine is
i'm gonna i'm gonna be moving into a
second job of making coffee very very
soon okay so listen uh justin bieber has
been diagnosed with something called
ramsay hunt syndrome uh it happens
it's basically shingles based we don't
have to go into detail but it's when a
shingles outbreak shingles is related to
um chickenpox right it's when a shingles
outbreak
affects the facial nerve okay it has
nothing to do with the vaccine
whatsoever i don't even know if justin
bieber's vaccinated quite frankly haley
bieber justin bieber's wife
did have a small stroke recently again
no idea whether she's vaccinated and no
evidence whatsoever that it has anything
to do with the vaccine and remember
when all you have is a hammer everything
everything looks like a nail when bob
saggett died of blunt force trauma to
the head
candace owens said this is a vaccine
death and
then of course the autopsy came out and
it was not um sometimes people you know
i've told i've told the story uh of my
late cousin fabian bielinski a
well-known argentinian
movie director
of nine queen fame and many other great
films when he was in his mid-40s he went
to brazil for a production
and he had a heart attack and died
and sometimes these things happen and if
you want to just blame everything on
vaccines that someone may or may not
have received you certainly can do it
but i prefer to stay in the world of
evidence
and reality that's just me you do you do
you
eric from mass on today's bonus show i
will describe to you the insanity of my
last uh eight days on planet earth yeah
it's crazy we will also talk about the
massive dumping of the stock market and
crypto and the bear market and
everything that's going on is a
recession coming you know i don't make
predictions but it's a question people
are asking i don't make predictions i'm
not going to tease that i'm going to
predict on the bonus show oh the bonus
show oh the bonus show or you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad i'm not
going to predict that uh i'm not gonna
make any predictions but i will promise
a good time on today's bonus show sign
up at joinpacman.com
uh take pleasure in my misery that i
will describe to you from the last eight
days of dealing with a newborn
all of that and more when producer pat
joins me on today's bonus show